-We are in the Doom Box,
and our next three stars
will decide
tonight's champions.
It's time for
Slay It, Don't Spray It!
Here we go.
♪♪
Here's how this works.
On your turn, you're gonna
have to sing
a well-known song karaoke-style.
You have the lyrics
in front of you,
but when the music drops out,
you have to finish
the line from memory.
If you don't get
the lyrics exactly right,
those microphones will spray you
and your partner in the face
with water.
I apologize.
But if you can slay it and sing
all the words perfectly,
then your opponents
get drenched instead.
-Oh, man, we're screwed.
-Each song is worth
50,000 points.
All right, Patti and Billy,
your team is up first.
Let's see what song you get.
-Are you gonna sing this one?
-"Ain't No Mountain
High Enough."
-It was nice knowing you dry.
-Yeah. Hey, it was nice.
It was fun while it lasted.
-Yeah.
-You guys should be --
You should be nervous.
-We're very nervous.
-You should be very nervous.
-We're very scared.
-♪ Patti, Patti ♪
-Here we go.
Whenever you're ready,
"Ain't No Mountain High Enough."
Sorry, guys.
-Ah.
[ Song plays ]
-Whoo!
♪♪
♪ If you need me, call me ♪
♪ No matter where you are,
no matter how far ♪
-♪ Don't worry, baby ♪
-♪ Just call my name,
I'll be there in a hurry ♪
♪ You don't have to worry ♪
♪ 'Cause, baby, there ♪
♪ Ain't no mountain
high enough ♪
♪ Ain't no valley low enough ♪
♪ Ain't no river wide enough ♪
-♪ To keep me from
getting to you, babe ♪
-Ugh! Oh!
-You knew that was
gonna happen?
-Yes.
-I put my hands up.
-Patti LaBelle!
-Okay. All right.
-Let's see that again
in slow motion
just to see
what happened to you guys.
Yeah, you knew -- yeah, you see,
you knew it was gonna happen.
-Oh, wow.
-Darren and Sarah, let's see
what song you get.
-We can just go home and put
water on our own face.
-Totally fine.
I'm not gonna get
all of these.
-Okay!
-I just dance too hard
to this song.
-Okay.
You got "Juice" by Lizzo.
Which one of you knows
"Juice" better?
-I think it's --
I think it's Sarah.
-Oh, don't make me -- don't --
Don't make me sing.
-Make me sing!
Here comes the music, Sarah.
Whenever you're ready.
-Oh, God.
-Go.
[ Music plays ]
-Gosh darn it.
-♪ That's how I roll ♪
♪ If I'm shining,
everybody gonna shine ♪
[ Sings gibberish ]
♪ I was born like this,
don't even gotta try ♪
♪ I'm like chardonnay,
get better over time ♪
♪ Heard you say I'm not
the baddest chick, you lie ♪
♪ It ain't my fault that
I'm out here getting loose ♪
♪ Gotta blame it on the Goose ♪
♪ Gotta blame it on my juice,
baby ♪
♪ It ain't my fault that
I'm out here making news ♪
♪ I'm the [bleep] ♪
Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-Oh!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Ah, I'm from New York!
I'm sorry I cursed, everyone!
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-[bleep]
Oh!
[ Distorted laughter ]
-That was bound to happen.
And you knew it.
-You knew it! I told you.
-I didn't know we were gonna
have to bleep words out.
I didn't know.
-I'm sorry!
It just comes out of me.
I can't help it.
-"I'm the pudding in the proof,
gotta blame it on my juice."
-I'm the pudding in the proof.
-I was close.
-It's time for the final round.
Watch your heads,
because we got
the big microphones coming in.
-Is that like a larger spray?
-Watch your heads.
It's about to get wetter.
-Sorry. I'm sorry.
-What is this?
-I apologize.
-I apologize in advance.
-This is more water?
-Yeah, it's more water.
Yes, it is.
-I feel it dripping.
-They didn't do that
in season one.
[ Laughter ]
-Pay attention to your screen.
-I was ready for a little bit
of water
-Switch off line by line.
When the music stops,
you have to nail the lyrics,
or you and your partner
will get drenched.
This round is worth
200,000 points.
Whoever wins this,
wins the whole thing.
Let's see what
our final song is.
-Oh!
-"It's Raining Men,"
hallelujah,
by The Weather Girls.
It's kinda like it is
raining in here.
-It is raining.
-You got the vibe.
-Girls, cats, and dogs.
-Here we go.
-Whoo!
[ Song plays ]
-Patti, you start off first.
-♪ Is rising, oh ♪
-Sarah, you're up next.
-♪ Barometer's getting low ♪
-Billy.
-♪ According to our sources ♪
-Darren.
-♪ The street's the place
to go ♪
-Patti.
-♪ 'Cause tonight
for the first time ♪
-Sarah.
-♪ Just about half past 10 ♪
-Billy.
-♪ For the first time ♪
In history, it's gonna start
raining men ♪
-Darren.
-♪ It's raining men ♪
♪ Hallelujah,
it's raining men, amen ♪
-Patti.
-♪ I'm gonna go out ♪
♪ I'm gonna let myself get ♪
♪ Absolutely soaking wet ♪
Whoo!
[ Laughter ]
-She nailed it!
-Ohhhh!
-We made it through
with no water!
-Yeah!
-Patti, Billy, get out here.
You are the champs!
-Go on, baby.
Whoo! Oh, wow!
-No water!
We're dry.
-We're in time-out.
-You're in time-out.
-It's all right.
Thank you so much.
-You don't want to hug us?
We're so wet.
-Absolutely soaking wet.